Những nhà ăn thật sự bằng con đam nè ở y thật với con ăn, ở xúc hệ ở đây bị là ngàn thang hả mà,
cái bằng có thể hòm tòn đến với trường đồng ý,
nó tòo ăn của bố lối tàn là kếm mất điểm,
mà sẽ bự xung này thì nó phải bằng ở cái đường chủng như thế là nó bằng đồng bà.
Trách chắc mục đều là có tốt thì và không phải cắn đến đây.
Bớt cái đường này là trách chắc hềm sẽ là ở nhà tế bị đây là một cái tàn đến,
cho các bạn có thể tham gia sếp điểm, bằng bự xung,
và hòa như thế chúng ta cũng là bốt để những chủng rồi.
Thì kê làm chủng của chúng ta cũng bằng với cái này mà chúng ta đã cũng bố đó.
Nên chếm vì vậy, với những cái học lực của mình,
với những trả năng của mình, bằng ngoài là em bằng có thể sự dụng những cái phương thức khác.